comédie lui raconte sa jeunesse par
toutatis
merci mon chéri caroline vous voulez
alors vous êtes vous êtes magnifique en
plus je vais pas vous faire essayer ci a
voulu essayer c'est vrai alors caroline
essayé voyais rien et vous avez fait
comme ça alors on va voir se tenir sur
le lot et à essayer de trouver de tirer
sur le bouton rouge
pardon monsieur alors monsieur vais
aller dit oui c'est pas le stress est
dans la bonne direction
c'est dans la bonne direction si vous
avez dit est-ce que dans le public il ya
quelqu'un qui voudrait nous aider
quelqu'un qui joue un petit peu au foot
kaka qui joue plus au foot dans le
public ya quelqu'un là claque à monsieur
oui oui oui monsieur
[Applaudissements]
c'est beau mondial
aujourd'hui
on adore alors on se regarde un peu nos
coiffures parce que c'est vrai qu'on est
un petit peu dans le milieu de la
coiffure et du sport je sais que j'adore
merci je kiffe devons faire c'est ça te
va très bien que ça va empirer d'amour
c'est djibril et je voudrais le dire
c'est un mec exceptionnel à chaque fois
que l'appel pour une association audrey
il est toujours là c'est un mec qui a un
coeur énorme que j'aime énormément parce
qu ils sont fous mais voilà il a pas
pour vous il vient juste pour le kiff et
il vient juste pour aider les enfants tu
es vraiment un amour merci tu vas
essayer de faire gagner des enfants à
ouattara tirent
je le dis parce que c'est comme caroline
caroline mardi à côté de moi car mon
c'est comme quand tu vois le bouton la
sao maxime ces petits comme un assez
petit je sais que c'est petit à petit
attention ben vas-y et 56e de patois
[ __ ] en l'air sans arrière au niveau
et djibril cissé
l'immense tarn s'est pas trop et sert
autant fait trembler crois pas trop la
tête quand même c'est pas loin c'est pas
loin
djibril sacko témoin c'est pas grave
c'est pas à eux est-ce qu'on a quelqu'un
d'autre dans le public qui vont essayer
soit quelqu'un d'entier hopley quelqu'un
d'autre j'aimerais une fille une fille
qui joue au foot foulon
à shanghai
[Musique]
bonjour à tous d'après ma chérie merci
d'être là toi aussi tu es toujours un
amour voilà je le dis très franchement
voilà peut-être fait plaisir de voir
l'or toujours bas lors des minimes en
joueuse aussi l'or tu vas essayer de
faire gagner pour les enfants alors les
chenilles baba bien sûr tu peux te pieds
nus vas-y fais toi plaisir mets toi à
l'aise en mer elle a voulu faire la
bogoss belle quand elle me dira il
dépote et tu te prends pas le cio du
mois je veux quand même faire la boucle
a beau gosse alors et giroud dire après
ce qu'il y aura à gagner pour
l'association il pour le public c'est
énorme
mais non c'était très belle comme ça
aussi je te le dis basi machin attention
quoique à saïx à seix pied gauche pied
gauche vous avez déjà taillé quand il
s'est retourné
quel gosse belge quel gosse belle vas-y
ma chérie c'est merveilleux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les cherry ou des stores des loosers
c'est difficile c'est pour ça qu'on en
resterait ce carnivore
une troisième personne peut-être qui
veut nous donner une troisième personne
ne sait pas dans l'oubli
y a pas quelqu'un alors les champions de
ski
[Applaudissements]
merci merci le bla
en plus des dons et sa qualité de père
finn
voilà ce match de ouf merci d'être là
frérot merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu
présent merci au psg alors frérot il ya
des cadeaux à faire gagner pour les
enfants je sais que tu joue la ligue des
champions le chèque que tu gagnes des
championnats mais là chez des cadeaux il
ya un truc rouge là bas les mecs et
franchement choupo ce que je sais qu'il
est apte au montât pas le chou pauvres
ouais ça ça je sais vraiment pas facile
alors tu sais quoi essayer de nous faire
gagner c'est cadeau il a plusieurs
essais ou pas cette chose si ce n'est la
taille d'un accord ça je sais que la
taille d'un but c'est pas ça mais bon
c'est déjà tu me parles autres
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attention à l'oreille c'est très dur il
peut le faire une école petit le truc
peut le faire waouh
[Applaudissements]
m
ouais
[Applaudissements]
maximo lors des divorces d'avis et
gagner mon chéri d'amour
[Applaudissements]